مشاهدينا مثل ما هو متوقع اول مجموعه من
المقابلات للامير هاري للترويج لكتاب
مذكراته البث الدنيا مذكرات الامير مقرر
انها تطرح رسميا غدا في عشره يناير لكنها
تسربت وعرضت للبيع مبكرا في اسبانيا وفي
اطار الترويج لها اعلن عن مجموعه من
المقابلات المنتظره للامير وعرض منها
بالفعل حتى الان مقابلتين الاولى مع اي تي
في البريطانيه والثانيه مع سكس الامريكيه
ومثل ما قلنا ومثل ما هو متوقع المقابلات
حملت مجموعه قنابل جديده من الاتهامات
وتصريحات الموجهات ضد العائله الملكيه
قولي المقابلات التي عرضت كانت مع اي تي
في وابرز ما حملت من تصريحات كان التاريخ
اعضاء من العائله المالكه تعاملت مع
الشيطان بحسب وصفه ويقصد طبعا بهذا
الموضوع الصحفي الصفراء وهذا الحكي لتحسين
سمعتهم على حساب سمعته هو وزوجته ايضا
تحدث عن غروب ومع اسرته الى الولايات
المتحده وقال انه كان خوفا على حياته
حياتهم قال انه تصرفات العائله في جنازه
جدته الملكه التي نزلت كانت مروعه
ورغم كل هذا قال الامير هاري انه يرغب في
المصالحه مفتوح لكن والده شقيقه والعائله
هم اللي لم يظهروا اي رغبه في التصالح
عموما كثير من قيل في مقابله اي تي في
يتكرر كمان في مقابله سكس بنات ايضا في
وثائقي همم ايضا اتكرر في وثائقي نتفلكس
لعرض مؤخرا الامير تحدث مجددا عن تعاون
القصر مع الصحفي الصفراء لا نقل اخبار
وقصص غير حقيقيه عنه وعن زوجته
انا تعبان شويه
ماي واي
[موسيقى]
من المفاجات التي تفجرها الحري كمان في
مقابل
العائله مسؤوليه وصول متاخرا لبلمورو عند
وفاه جدته قال انه لم تتم دعوته للسفر
معهم الى هناك هاري كمان اعترف ايضا
بتعطيل المخدرات لتجاوز حزن على والدته
وقال ايضا انه خدمته في سلاح الجو في
افغانستان ساعده على تخطي الازمه امريكا
في مذكرات وتحدث كمان عن تعطيل المخدرات
في شبابه وايضا عن قتله 25 من المسلحين
طالبان في افغانستان خدمته هناك هاري في
مقابله سكس ايضا كامله زوجته
وصفها بشريره والخطيره
حقيقه مسلسل غير منتهي او في الحقيقه هو
مسلسل غير منتهي ولا يبدو انه راح ينتهي
قريبا كل هذه التصريحات الجداليه
والتهامات والادراما يضاف اليها ما ورد في
مذكراته واللي لا تقل جدليه والدراما
وتناولناها احنا تفصيلا امس يعني تفاصيل
عن فقدانه عذريته على يد امراه بتكبره سنا
في حقل وكلام كمان عن مشاهد ماجين
الحميميه اثناء اعمالها كممثله وخناقه مع
اخوه الامير وليام ضربوا خلالها وغيرها
كمان من الفضائيه
في الكتاب تطرق ايضا فضيحه
في قضيه اعتداء جنسي تم تسميتها لاحقا
وبهذا اصبح هو اول عضو في العائله المالكي
يعلق على القضيه امام كل هذه الصراحه من
يعني من غير المستغرب انه يسيطر الموضوع
على الترند العالمي وبيوقت في طاعته في
كبير لكن المقابلات والمذكرات على الاقل
الى الانش علىته كمان عرضه للكثير من
الانت وحتى الهاشتاج الاكثر تداولا عالميا
هو برنس
وترجمته الامير هاري اصيب بالجنون
[موسيقى]